die strategie zur verteidigung der
hauptstadt das analysiert jetzt julian
röcke in seinem lagezentrum
[Musik]
ja auch heute wollen wir uns wieder die
wichtigsten fakten rund um die
militärischen strategie beider seiten in
der ukraine ansehen anfang wollen wir
mit der verteidigung von kifir gucken
uns das erst mal auf der karte an kiew
die hauptstadt natürlich hier im norden
des landes und wir haben es gesehen in
den letzten tagen die russischen truppen
stecken davor fest sind aber weiterhin
in der nähe und wir wollen uns alle ist
es mal eine szene angucken die westlich
von kiew gespielt hat und zwar auf der
wichtigen autobahn e 90 das ist die
autobahn die nach mir und dann auch
weiter in den westen des landes führt
und die wir sehen uns hier von den
russischen soldaten immer noch an
verschiedenen orten gelagert wird und
festgehalten wird
wir gucken uns das mal an hier sehen wir
und das ist sehr interessant eine
hochpräzisions artillerie der
ukrainischen einheiten was wir säen
markiert jetzt schon das ist natürlich
bearbeitet worden im nachhinein sind die
russischen militär fahrzeuge die direkt
an der straße stehen an dieser wichtigen
straße und wir sehen jetzt wie dort die
einschläge passieren und zwar nicht
irgendwo sondern wirklich direkt auf
diesen fahrzeugen und insofern gibt es
viele experten die davon ausgehen dass
hier ist keine ungelenke artillerie aus
dem sowjetischen zeiten sondern das ist
leser gelenkte artillerie die eben genau
von einer drohne koordiniert diese
drohen bilder sehen wir hier oben auf
einen bestimmten punkt schießt und dann
eben jeden panzer jedes gepanzerte
fahrzeug dort eintreffen kann insofern
relativ interessant weil bisher auch
nicht bekannt war dass die ukraine über
solch eine moderne art rhi verfügt sie
tut es offenbar und wir sehen hier die
einschläge und wir sehen wie gesagt am
ende wieder die panzer die wir am anfang
gesehen haben dort auch brennen und so
ein panzer jahres ungefähr acht meter
lang wir sehen hier das hinten den tank
hier vorne ist die
dass das panzer rohr sozusagen das ist
sehr schwer zu treffen natürlich wir
gucken uns noch mal kurz die karte an
denen wir gucken uns jetzt mal die
region östlich von kiew an auch dort
wurden die russischen truppen
zurückgeschlagen wir sehen uns hier ist
gar kein rot mehr zu sehen
nichtsdestotrotz geht es dort weiter
schwere kämpfe und bei diesen kämpfen
und dass es interessant kämpfen nicht
nur ukrainer da kämpfen auch immer mehr
der freiwilligen westlichen ehemaligen
soldaten die in das land gegangen sind
um es zu verteidigen gegen putins
aggressionen wir sehen uns das mal an
und wir hören auch mal ein bisschen rein
wie man ein bisschen leise wir hören
hier englische stimmen wir hören hier
ja
wir hören hier ein mann der heißt james
marsters
wir sehen auch hier nochmal
wir halten das mal hier an er erzählt
was dort passiert ist dass er mit seinen
jungs diesen diesen panzer und
schützenpanzer dort also ausgenommen hat
sozusagen beseitigt hat das ganze ist
etwa 60 kilometer östlich von kiew er
ist einer der freiwilligen der dort
kämpfen james last hat am 25
februar einen tag nach beginn der
russischen invasion gesagt mir reicht's
ich habe früher in der armee gekämpft
ich gehe jetzt in die ukraine kämpfe
dort freiwillig er selbst bezeichnet
sich eigentlich als heimwerker
unternehmen also jemand der mit geräten
zu tun hat aber nichts mit dem militär
zu tun hat und er ist jetzt dort in
diesem land
kämpft zusammen der ukrainischen armee
und er so einer von 16.000 freiwilligen
westlichen ausländern seien oder
westliche ausländer wir sehen auch leute
aus georgien beispielsweise die dort
heute aktiv sind insofern auch hier ja
unfassbare bilder dass dort menschen
kämpfen die nicht als söldner dort
kämpfen nicht viel geld dort kämpfen
sondern aus idealistischen gründen
direkt nach ausbruch des krieges dorthin
gegangen sind wir wollen jetzt aber zum
schluss auch noch mal wie immer ja für
die ukraine sehr unschöne szenen ansehen
nämlich den russischen vormarsch der
russische vormarsch wir haben es vor
zwei tagen gehört ist in vielen
landesteilen zu ersticken gekommen aber
im osten ist es nicht so der kreml hat
gesagt wir konzentrieren uns auf die
sogenannten volks republiken also
marionettenregime des kreml die 2014
eingerichtet wurden und wollen diese
jetzt wie es heißt im kreml befreien
also besetzen sozusagen eine invasion
weiter in die kleine hineinwagen
gucken uns noch einmal kurz die karte an
was wir jetzt jetzt angucken ist hier im
osten des landes die region lugansk und
wir sehen dieses dunkelrote sind die
alten die alten gebiete die besetzten
gebiete seit 2005 das rote darüber und
darunter alles schon neu besetzt und wir
sehen der größte teil ist hier
mittlerweile erobert der regionen
lugansk und donetsk und wie das da ganz
genau aussieht das gucken uns jetzt mal
an in einem video was russische reporter
wenn man so möchte mit der russischen
armee zusammen vorrückende aktivisten
dort gedreht haben als alle ist es ein
bisschen verwackelt was wir sehen ist
ein ukrainischer raketenwerfer bzw 1 ein
haltesystem für diese raketen was ihr
komplett zerstört wurde und am
straßenrand liegt dort ist es so dass
die russische armee vorrückt und
gehalten das video gleich einmal an
werden wir wenn wir eine
verteidigungsposition sehen der ukraine
die russen sind auch sehr aktiv in den
sozialen medien sehr aktiv auch für ihre
staatsmedien und nehmen alles auf was
sie dort was sie dort was sie dort sehen
sozusagen und jetzt kann ein kurzer
stopp drücken hier sehen wir die
ukrainische flagge das ist eine
ukrainische position die erobert wurde
von den pro russischen truppen und
russischen soldaten in ruby china heißt
die stadt wir gehen einfach mal weiter
hier sind sozusagen die russen extrem
stolz auf das was erobert haben und so
gut ist auch weiterhin um kiew
herumläuft und auch in anderen
landesteilen so aussichtslos scheint die
lage für die organischen truppen hier in
diesen regionen donetsk und lukas die
tatsächlich ja sich weiterhin wären so
gut sie können aber wir sehen uns hier
die position der ukrainischen armee
wurden erobert und die russen dringen
hier weiter vor und ja wir haben schon
den letzten tagen gesagt wenn dort nicht
bald neue ukrainische truppen aber auch
die westlichen waffen gegen panzer und
flugzeuge ankommen dann sieht es
tatsächlich so aus als könnten die
russen hier weiter vorrücken und hier
weiter ihre ziele im osten der ukraine
zumindest auch erfüllen